[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when i was growing up i wanted to do
what brent mussberger did
on the cbs pregame show he was the king
and he's still doing it the raiders
play-by-play voice lead broadcaster
and uh brent joining us now good morning
brent how are you
good morning danny good to be talking to
you lad here we are
midway point nfl raiders
raiders still alive still alive in that
wild card battle don't think they'll run
down the chiefs but
hey you moved up in class mercedes-benz
a sponsor
that's big time that's big time my man
how's this going over with uh las vegas
the raiders get fined
over a million dollars and lost a draft
pick
yeah yeah yeah you know the covert
restrictions
are the covert restrictions and the
league does what the league does um
i'm gonna be perfectly honest i uh
i am not permitted inside the facility
or or out to practice and i understand
it and
and i have stayed away with i i felt
some sympathy
for my buddy john gruden when he was
fined earlier this year dan a hundred
thousand
because the mass kept coming down in the
night game against the new orleans
saints here
uh i'm i'm really not up to speed with
all the details
about the situation regarding trent
brown obviously he was not wearing the
monitor
around his wrist and that led to
exposure to some different players
and then he went shoe shopping with one
of our safeties with
allegedly shoe shopping you know that's
a that's a main attraction here in las
vegas
shoe shopping but at any rate uh we lost
abram
uh for a game so just to let people know
brenda's mentioning
shoe shopping that is uh
women dancing exotic dance
adult entertainment right brent yeah
exactly
exactly okay
i i like what i'm seeing with the
raiders i think they're a playoff team
and also i was looking at the numbers
with
uh derek carr his completion percentage
his quarterbacking quarterback rating
and completion percentage has increased
every season since 2017
he's up to 71 percent completion his
quarterback rating is 110.
those are impressive numbers um you know
his interception percentage is the fifth
lowest among
uh qualifiers in nfl history
in history um so what is it uh you know
what are the raiders missing this year
uh defense defense and defense okay they
cannot
they now last week they used the weather
to their advantage and they were able to
shut down uh
baker mayfield but you and i know that
when you have a fierce wind like they
face up in cleveland
gusting upwards of 35 miles an hour it
was much easier to shut a quarterback
down because accuracy was so difficult
um derek carr and john gruden have
been on the same page now for for some
time
there was an over as there always is
when a team loses and doesn't perform
well
the media in particular uh jumps on the
quarterback and and quarterbacks
understand that
around the league but it was never derek
carr's
fault when they struggled and john's
system
is is difficult especially when it comes
to terminology the number plays he calls
a very insistent he has pushed dan he
has pushed derek carr
to run more i think he ran for a couple
of first downs
against cleveland two the week before
quarterbacks in the nfl when things
break down and they see it they can
they can move the sticks for a first
down they have to take off those are the
most successful quarterbacks
and derrick carr has been doing that
he's on the same page with john
um with the west coast offense and now
with henry ruggs
and rux gaining more and more experience
a speedster out of
alabama they'll be able to get downfield
a little more often when you watched
aaron rodgers last night you watched the
king of receivers
outside the numbers now traditionally
those are the most difficult throws for
a quarterback in the nfl when i say
outside the numbers
if you're moving down and you get close
to the sideline we call that outside the
numbers nobody is better than devante
adams as he demonstrated again last
night
and i would assume as time goes forward
as he works on route running
rugs will be very very lethal outside
the numbers because he'll be
he'll beat the defensive backs by a step
and a half he's got elite speed
so things looking up offensively but
it is the defense and we'll see what the
young impressive rookie of the chargers
justin herbert is able to do against the
raiders this week i think this is a very
tricky game
for the raiders the chargers have to be
that the chargers have perfected the art
of blowing big leads uh they've got to
be an angry football team this week
i was also curious about this vegas had
the packers
as a six and a half point favorite last
night and i kept thinking what am i
missing here
because san francisco is decimated
packers get their starting running back
back there's no real home field
advantage
and you got aaron rodgers and davonte
adams and i kept thinking
there's something up here and i i
thought it would be like a 10 and a half
11
11 and a half point spread there so you
get people
to think because if there was going to
be a blowout it was going to be green
bay blowing out the niners
and you might just take the money or the
the line there the points
with san francisco so what what was
vegas missing last night on this game
now vegas wasn't missing anything uh
they knew what the packard defense had
done the previous week against alvin
cook
and they know what kyle shanahan likes
to do is run the football mckinnon was
back
he missed last year with an injury he's
a solid running back they expected
they expected the 49ers to come running
you have to be careful when you move a
line up to
uh to 10 points because two things
happen number one
those who just bet that opening number
or where
rotates to will automatically take the
10 10 and a half and then
those of us who like to tease i.e me we
would immediately go up to 16
and uh include that in our teaser with
the 49ers so there's a
there's a couple of things that
bookmakers have to look at uh
and they there was money bet on san
francisco even even with that particular
opening line
especially how much respect they have
for for coach shanahan
what's the worst bet you ever made
last week the new york jets taking the
points against the kansas city chiefs
i always i always remember my worst most
recent bet if you know what i mean dad
[Laughter]
how about a great one
well last night i teased the packers
down to one
and i teased the over under number up to
54
and a half and went the under that was a
good bet because
the regular over under went down with
that last touchdown when they put it up
over the 50 mark
that was a huge money mover uh last
night in the packers 49ers game
i lost a game the packers and the bears
and chester markle all he had to do was
kick
kick a field goal
and he kicks it it's blocked he gets it
and he runs it in for a touchdown
that was my bad beat brent i
listen i remember that i knew where you
were headed as soon as you mentioned
chester marco
okay were you betting when you were
doing the pre-game show
no i was actually being educated by
jimmy the greek
um you know i suppose occasionally i
would
i would come here when we weren't
covering the super bowl and i would come
out
and make a bet but but basically
i didn't i was a total innocent about
point spread betting growing up as a kid
in montana it did
my education came later it was uh
generally jimmy the greek
and many many of us know that when the
greek made a move go the other way
[Laughter]
it's amazing how far we've come though
with betting
with all the sports in particular the
nfl where do you think we're going to be
in five years when it comes to betting
in the nfl well states states are going
to continue to be added
uh to those who have it legalized i
think in this recent election i think i
saw that three more states legalized it
uh including maryland i know that
colorado wasn't up for speed
i think we'll continue to grow but i you
know i i warn
everybody and i do this all the time if
you think you're going to walk in
and you're going to immediately make a
lot of money
think otherwise okay
those numbers are very very difficult to
beat on a regular basis
now if you're fifty dollar better like i
am
occasionally up to a hundred for
recreation i think that's fine i don't i
don't have a problem
last night it actually enhanced i'd had
enough of the election coverage and so
i was able to watch a football game with
with a little added interest but
but i just danny i especially for
youngsters i i keep stressing
yes i think it's part of it i we're
gonna have it
but be careful there are very very few
people
who can make big money uh trying to beat
those numbers
week in and week out so just don't think
don't think that you're gonna oh i can
do that i can no you can't
okay uh that that's my alert but it's
gonna be with us
it's it's part of the nfl it helped the
nfl become what it is today
uh people enjoy it whether it's just
picking winners
or or going against the spread or over
unders and now all these propositions
uh that are out there everybody can
but you don't want to get in over your
head just just please
please don't i keep trying to stress
that because i'm someone
who really enjoys it who thought it
should be legalized
and now that we have it especially
youngsters have to pay attention
this is not under any circumstance an
easy way to get rich let me let me just
tell you that right now
i'm also wondering brent once we get
back to
whatever normal is where fans can go to
the stands could you see
an actual betting parlor in stadiums
that you know you have to become a
member to get in you have to have cash
to bet
or debit cards and that you could bet
you know almost like you have in the
premier league
but have a sports book at a stadium
well there's no question uh now it's not
day after tomorrow that this is going to
come
but there's no there's no question it is
going to happen because when you look
around the league i believe it was the
indianapolis colts who signed up a
casino
uh first of all they're the first team
to align themselves with it
and that's the initial move and then as
as time goes on
the league and the league really if you
look around uh it's amazing how quickly
the league has accepted it i mean there
are sponsors and broadcasts
uh william hill i see them up all the
time
um they were going to be bought in the
united states by caesars and caesar's
going to rebrand it
caesar's a big story in las vegas here
this morning
but absolutely like the premier league
down in australia
they've got betting kiosks that you can
go into down there to
better australian rules football as the
game is unfolding there's certainly that
that is to come but i don't it's not day
after tomorrow i mean
it's going to take years if not decades
before we get to that but we're headed
in that direction
what's the first game you called oh
any first game i call would would have
been a chicago bear pre-season game
um i was the spotter lindsay nelson
george halas really liked lindsay nelson
because lindsay
did um with a review of the notre dame
games on television
early on sunday morning okay with paul
and and george halas was very fond of
lindsay so lindsay did
chicago bear preseason games i became
lindsay's spotter and he was such a
such a nice man i was working locally in
chicago
and then lindsay couldn't do it any
longer
probably because of his new york mets
responsibilities i don't quite remember
the circumstance
and uh so george connor of the old great
linebacker
great defensive player he was the
analyst and uh
they asked me to do the play-by-play and
i don't i really don't
we used to play believe it or not the
packers um every preseason
so i and they would play in milwaukee
not green bay or chicago sort of a
neutral site the old county stadium
so that was probably my first uh
play-by-play that i ever did
did you have any interaction with
lombardi
a lot as a newspaper man of the 60s
i was around vince a lot and when i
first met him i was scared to death of
him
uh i was a tiptoe when i go in after a
game
normally he was on the winning side what
what i found with lombardi
it was very strange i'm not sure i've
ever found this with a with a coach
after a win he was more cantankerous
than after a loss now granted he didn't
lose many games
but he was the most gracious loser
that i ever had to interview uh after a
game
i remember in 1963 paul horning had been
suspended
for gambling by commissioner rozelle and
the bears
were able to to win the conference and
go on to win the nfl championship in
chicago against the new york giants and
so
we handled the packers during that
season and
i probably would not have if horny had
been playing to tell you the truth but
anyway
no one was ever nicer and when you went
to green bay
on friday night friday night
he would he would have a no it was
saturday night actually was saturday
night
he would especially new york riders he
was very friendly with red smith
and some of the others because he'd been
a long time assistant coach with the
giants
but he always had a nice cocktail party
uh over at his house very modest house
and we would all get together and have a
cold beer and uh
talk and he he didn't talk about the
game and he always said there's nothing
i can do about it now
the game plan is in and we'll go see
what it is i always remember my time
with vince
party i had enormous respect for him
covered the uh
super bowl one and he felt so much
pressure
for the nfl to win that game and beat
the kansas city chiefs
he took the chiefs up to santa barbara
and basically locked them away from us
hanks graham and the chiefs went into
long beach and they were wide open every
day you go watch practice
go talk to coach stram a completely
different build-up and that
coach coach lombardi later told me that
he felt that the weight
of the entire nfl was on his shoulders
to win that game and of course they did
in
dramatic fashion and storybook faction
max mcgee having stayed out basically
half the night not thinking that he was
going to play and then because of an
injury
to the wide receivers he became bart
star's receiving star so yeah i was
around
i was around coach a lot and i really
really enjoyed my experience with it
yeah i could understand that you know
there's a little tip-toeing or
trepidation when you're around some of
these
you know that was that way for me with
tom lander it was that way for me with
don
shula uh with bob knight for a little
while
where and then all of a sudden like you
have to kind of work your way in
where i don't know if you prove yourself
but i just kept showing up
and if you keep asking questions and uh
you know i eventually became very good
friends with don schula
uh coach landry i did not i did not know
him
that well chuck noll was a guy who
intimidated me as well
but you just kind of hang in there and
hold on for dear life sometimes
exactly exactly i did that with woody
hayes also
uh and actually it was not until woody
was uh
replaced as head coach of ohio state
eric parseghian
i became one of my analysts and era and
woody were we're dear friends and rivals
and we would go into woody's office uh
after he'd been let go we would see him
every time we went to columbus
and and he became uh you know just a
cuddly old
grandfatherly type but i'm going to tell
you when i was a newspaperman and i'd
get sent in as a columnist to cover a
big ohio state game and you were around
woody
uh you were really careful around him at
the time [ __ ] buckler
intimidated me a little bit and like you
say you just keep going
you keep going and and finally they
actually become very good friends
um bo i've worked games with him
actually in the uh
in the booth so um but but you just hang
in like you said and that that is the
way to approach it and
it was it was different back in that day
i mean it was very very different when i
covered
baseball in the nfl i i would actually
run with some of the players after games
uh but we when under no circumstance
we write about going out and having a
beer after a game or anything like that
but it's it's entirely different now the
media is not as close to the players
and of course the athletes have to be so
careful when they go out because
everybody's got a cell phone which makes
everybody a reporter
and uh times have changed uh notre dame
plus five notre dame getting five
yeah not enough not enough for me okay
uh
i'll pass i think that's that's a game
that has to be at around the seven or
eight level
uh before i think about clemson uh you
know there's three teams
that you're looking at right now alabama
ohio state
and clemson they appear to me to be
headed for the playoffs and then
they can choose whoever they want to be
the fourth team but i think those three
i mentioned
dan are probably at an elite level great
to talk to you as always
and uh thank you thanks for sharing and
uh have fun this weekend
thanks dan talk to you soon all right
that's brent mussberger hall of famer
radio
uh play-by-play voice with the raiders